now a senior official at the european
medicines agency has said there
is a link between the astrazeneca covet
19 vaccine
and blood clots last week germany
suspended routine use of the vaccine and
people under 60 years of age
that was after nine people who had
received the vaccine died from rare
blood clotting
the ema is expected to issue an update
to its advice later today
and let's get some perspective on the
story now from the uk we're joined by dr
julian tang he's a virologist in the
city of
leicester welcome to dw now we keep
seeing the astrazeneca vaccine being
linked to these
rare blood clots and i want to get your
opinion on this
how safe is this vaccine
okay so the first thing to say is that
this vaccine is safer than having the
virus itself you know that covert 19
causes
lots of complications including blood
clots at a much higher frequency than
the vaccine
so relative to the virus itself getting
the vaccine is safer
there are concerns however about these
rare blood clots that we're seeing do we
know what factors make people more
likely to develop these clots
okay so there's a difference here the
natural infection
causes more clotting complications in
older
male patients and those who have
diabetes and obesity
for the astrocytic vaccine proposed
adverse effect
we've seen this in younger females so
almost the opposite picture to what we
see with the virus infection
i suspect all of this is linked to a
kind of hyperinflammatory response that
you've seen some people
and not in others in both the vaccine
response
adverse effect as well as the virus
natural infection
what about in the uk because we know
that millions of people have received
the astrazeneca vaccine there already
has the data shown similar cases of
these blood clots there
yeah so they've shown at least 30 cases
of which seven have died
uh in the younger population and uh
they're now trying they're proposing to
restrict the
uh astrazeneca to those who are older uh
like the over 30s for example um
part of the problem is that the uk is
actually so many people up to the age of
fifth over the age of 50 now
uh they can't restrict uh the afghan
vaccine
to much uh older people than 50. um
so it's slightly different from the from
the scandinavian and european approach
certainly i know that in germany finland
sweden and even canada
they've restricted the vaccine to those
who are over 55
and that's to protect the younger
population that seem to be more
vulnerable to this
severe adverse effects of the astrocenga
vaccine
you mentioned there the different
approaches that we're seeing in europe
like here in germany some will only
offer to people over the age of 60. so
what do you think is the right approach
the right way to administer this vaccine
so the people most vulnerable to severe
disease and death from covered 19 are
the older people
and we're seeing fewer of these adverse
effects from the vaccine in the older
population
so giving the vaccine to that older age
group the over 60s
over 55 seems to be a good idea to
actually you know hit two birds
two birds with one stone essentially
where you have to cut off
for the younger population is difficult
to say plus also you have other problems
with vaccine supply locally
as well as the other vaccines may have
other adverse effects as well as we
see in the fires that moderna vaccines
have been rolled across the usa in large
numbers
so i think every vaccine will have a
different profile and we have to try and
figure out which
population best benefits from the
vaccine with a few side effects
going forward and don't forget there are
relatively few of these adverse effects
with the astrocytic vaccine so far
with more and more cases coming forward
and i think there will be more
you might see a more kind of universal
profile that people can then
adapt to when making these vaccine
recommendations for the atrocenter
vaccine
we'll have to leave it there dr julian
tang a virologist
in leicester thank you so much for
joining us thank you